[Music]
when it comes to in jokes and easter
eggs no one does it better than the
house of mouse Disney movies are full of
really cool hidden secrets that keep
fans talking for years here are just a
few that you may have missed jungle
books beetles in 1967 Disney released
its take on the Rudyard Kipling classic
The Jungle Book with it swinging songs
it stars jazz musicians Phil Harris and
Louis Prima as Balu and King Louie
respectively but it also almost had some
rock and roll's if the filmmakers had
their way that is as you may have
noticed the four vultures who sing
that's what friends are for
have familiar English accents and mop
tops that's because they were modeled
after the Fab Four the Beatles but
according to one of the movies composers
the Beatles declined the invitation to
appear in the movie maybe the Rolling
Stones would have done it
Jeanne's ends at the beginning in 1992 s
Aladdin audiences meet a short wacky
peddler who introduces the story they're
about to see and then he's never seen
again or is over the years fans
theorized that the peddler is actually
the genie but after he's been set free
by the end of the movie spoilers the
evidence they both have four fingers on
their hands they both have the same
curly beards and they're both voiced by
Robin Williams but after years of
silence on the theory
Aladdin's co-directors Ron Clements and
John Musker confirmed that in 2015 that
guests the pepper and the genie are one
in the same
in this case fans wishes finally came
true Simba's parents everyone knows that
James Earl Jones provided the booming
voice for Mufasa
Simba's father in 1994 is the Lion King
Jones is also well known for his role as
King Jackie Joker father of Eddie
Murphy's prince Hakeem in 1988 coming to
America what most fans probably don't
know however is that King Joffrey's
royal wife Queen aaliyan was played by
actress Madge Sinclair and Sinclair also
provided the voice for Simba's mother
Surabhi clearly jones and sinclair were
a perfect royal match
Hercules is haunting muses Disney movies
are so filled with references that some
of them can slip by in a flash one such
example comes in 1997's Hercules which
features a quintet of the singing muses
who move the story along during Meg's
song I won't say I'm in love the muses
take the form of five stone busts and
they're arranged exactly like five
similar stone busts known as the grim
grinning ghosts from Disney's Haunted
Mansion rise the best way to tame a lion
lots of Disney characters make brief
unexpected cameos and other characters
films but usually in the form of a blink
and you'll miss it appearance in the
background but not always in the
original Greek myths
Hercules is tasked with fighting and
slaying the Nemean lion a fearsome beast
that no mortal can kill while we don't
see hercules fighting the lion in the
animated movie we definitely see that
fights loser the villain is scar from
The Lion King
too bad Mufasa never thought of that big
hero 6 is big heroic cameo even though
big hero 6 was a smash hit in 2014 a lot
of Disney fans might not know that it
was actually the first Disney animated
film to feature Marvel Comics characters
big hero 6 was originally a comic book
that debuted in 1998 but what's really
interesting is the cameo featuring the
most legendary Marvel character of them
all Stan Lee in the movies post credit
scene Fred and his dad bond over their
mutual love of wearing their underpants
four days in a row you know as one does
true Marvel Zombies can't miss the fact
that Fred's dad is voiced by and modeled
after Lee co-creator of spider-man the
Fantastic Four the Hulk Iron Man and
countless others even though he's been
in nearly every Marvel movie since x-men
in 2000 this is probably the one that
feels the most super wreckit-ralph
graffiti artists there's no shortage of
cameos from famous videogame characters
throughout 2012 wreck-it Ralph from King
Koopa Zangief to Sonic the Hedgehog
gamers were treated to tons of
appearances from heroes and villains who
would otherwise probably never get to
share a screen together but more than
that the world of wreck-it Ralph has
some even deeper cuts that only the most
dedicated fans can
when fix-it Felix and sergeant Calhoun
prepared to enter sugar rush graffiti
referencing famous games and in jokes
lined the walls mirrors earth lives
referencing Final Fantasy 7 there's a
nod to the infamous Leroy Jenkins as
well as a tag saying Sheng long was here
referencing Street Fighter 2 s most
important non character and of course no
gaming references would be complete
without all your base are belong to us
seems that the street artists in the
world of games love a good meme as much
as we do the all-powerful Konami code
out of all of racket routes many
references there's one that truly stands
out among them all when the villainous
King candy starts to enter the secret
vault to hack sugar rush his code he
pulls out a napkin with mysterious
instructions written on it up up down
down left right left right B a start if
you know what that is congratulations
you played Nintendo games in the 80s
that sequence of commands is known as
the Konami code and it first appeared as
a way to get power-ups and extra lives
in the NES games
Gradius and contra back in 1986 both
made by Japanese developer Konami the
code has since taken on mythical status
among fans and it's found its way into
plenty of other games and even websites
back to school if you keep your eyes
sharp you'll notice a recurring
combination of letters and numbers a 1 1
3 that keeps appearing in lots of
Disney's movies it shows up in meet for
Robinson The Princess and the Frog The
Brave Little Toaster and lilo and stitch
just to name a few
it also happens to appear in every
single Pixar movie why well that's just
the classroom number for the first year
graphic design and character animation
class at the California Institute of
Arts where many of the animators who've
worked at Disney and Pixar started out
the code even makes appearances and non
Disney properties like episodes of
FAMILY GUY and The Simpsons
so aspiring animators take note if you
want to get a job in showbiz now you
know exactly where to send your
application
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe if you want more
[Music]